Trong tâm dưới báo hí tưởng thủy văn cuộc ra, báo xuống mề lâm có sức gió mạnh nhất vùng gần tâm báo
mạnh cơm mề 2, tâm 1,5% đến 1,8% kỳ lũ mê một giờ, dật cơm mề lâm, dí chuyển theo hướng tây tế bắt,
tốc độ mề đến 1,5% kỳ lũ mê một giờ.
Cô vực giữa biển đông, báo gồm vùng biển phía bắt đặt khu trường xa, có gió mạnh cấp vải cấp chiến,
vùng gần tâm báo đi qua mạnh cấp mề mề 2, dật cấp mề lâm, sống biển cao từ bún đến xong mẽ, vùng gần tâm báo từ bẩy đến chiến mẽ,
biển đông dữ rồi. Tổ thuyền hỏng đồng trong các vùng uì hiểm nói trên, đều có khả năng chức tắc động của dồng
lốc, gió mạnh, xong lớn, báo xuống mề lâm dịn viến còn rất khó lượng về hướng đi. Trong mối cảnh, báo trồng lũ,
lũ trồng lũ, theo cảnh báo, lũ trên xong crom à nà và xong xrepo đằng xuống, trên xong bà của xong đồng,
trong 2 mì tư dở tới, lũ trên xong crom à nà tại xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong xong
tiếp tục xuống và ở dưới mức báo đồng 2, lũ trên xong bà tại xong cung xong xong đồng ở trên mức báo đồng môt,
ngọt lùn vấn sĩnh xong xong tại tính đặc lắc, mùi cơ sẩy zong ngọt lùo tại vùng trung thấp và xong tình xalai,
mùi cơ sẩy zong xong xong xong, các tình đặc lắc, càng báo cấp lộ dưới xong thêm tài, xong lũ, cấp môt.